[Musique]
bonsoir le 4 juin 2014
il est 16h30 quand je reçois un appel
d'une personne majeure a disparu on doit
lui porter secours sans délai le seul
élément dont il dispose à ce moment là
c'est le résultat de la géocalisation
son téléphone portable
on a une zone gigantesque à surveiller à
fouiller en fait pour vous la
représenter c'est une antenne relais de
téléphone
ces 10 km de circonférence vous avez une
zone de montagne avec des vallées
enfoncé 5h de visibilité devant tous
vous et vous n'avez que ça ça fait douze
heures qui n'a pas donné de nouvelles sa
famille est inquiète
on est tout en oeuvre à partir de larmes
par des reconnaissances aériennes pour
aller au plus vite au mieux et tenter
d'avoir une piste cinq heures de
visibilité avec tous les efforts du
monde
on n'arrivera pas à trouver piste compte
tenu de la zone immense que je vous ai
décrites
alors à partir de là en fait on va faire
autre chose on va prendre le problème en
anglais doit s'intéresser à qui a
disparu qui c'est adrien il a 21 ans est
en deuxième année de médecine et son
projet c'est dans un an de pouvoir aller
dans les andes péruviennes porter
assistance à des populations
défavorisées
il n'est pas difficile d'imaginer les
raisons pour lesquelles il est en
montagne il est parti pour s'entraîner
seul on peut lui faire grief de quoi de
ne pas avoir donné de renseignements sur
là où il est sa date de retour
le lendemain on à son véhicule à partir
de là on a un secteur
c'est une montagne elle est grande
en fait 2 500 mètres d'altitude ça va
jusqu'à 2007
ça fait plusieurs kilomètres de longueur
il faut qu'on m'avait ce terrain qu'on
cherche méthodiquement on déploie 40
gendarmes à 4 heures du matin on
retourne la montagne au sens propre
comme figuré
ces quarante gendarmes
ils sont animés d'une seule chose il est
de retrouver
adrien c'est pas une personne c'est pas
un numéro
c'est adrien c'est le gamin de 20 ans
qui a tout donné et qui sait donner tous
les moyens pour vivre son projet pour
les autres il ya besoin de nous on y va
et tout le monde est animé de cette même
espérance on va tout faire pour le
rendre à 18 heures g thomas thomas c'est
un des spécialistes de l'équipe
un professionnel de grande valeur qui
vient de trouver et qui me dit ceci
guillaume ya un secteur qu'on n'a pas
fouillé il est difficile d'accès ça va
être compliqué si on ne traite pas
maintenant donne-moi les moyens de
monter dans la machine
c'est pas compliqué vous me direz vous
la machine on là pour nous elle est
dédiée à notre à nos missions
c'est normal sauf que la machine à ce
moment là elle est pris sur notre
mission de secours
il faut croire arbitré sur des sur des
urgences de vie la question elle se pose
pas dans ces termes là ce que me dit
thomas ce moment là c'est essentiel
c'est guillaume en fait est ce que tu as
confiance en moi est-ce que tu as
confiance dans le dispositif qu'on a mis
en place qu'on a décidé
est-ce que tu as confiance dans les
quarante gendarmes qui cherchent et qui
font tout pour qu'on retrouve adrien sap
a pris en fait cinq secondes à partir du
mans ou jeudi
je me suis dit ça pour dire thomas dans
20 minutes et dans la machine
il lui a pas fallu cinq minutes à thomas
après son décollage pour me dire ceci on
l'a retrouvé on l'a retrouvé c'est pas
autre chose que l'expression du
collectif c'est pas je jette argué tg
strike est sur quelque chose quelqu'un
sait on l'a retrouvé quand il dit ça
c'est à la radio c'est à dire un réseau
où toutes les équipes qui sont engagées
sur le terrain dans des conditions
difficiles parce que la météo n'est pas
très bonne à haute altitude on trouve de
la neige oui malgré le mois de juin en
fait cette année là ce avait décidé de
traîner donc les équipes elles sont sur
le terrain elle cherche elle cherche
depuis de nombreuses heures et elles ont
tout donné
le on l'a retrouvé c'est tout le sens de
cette histoire
thomas il va aller il va décembre il va
relever pour la dernière fois de rien et
on va défendre sa dépouille
on restitue adrien sa famille est là
quelque chose d'extraordinaire interview
la famille nous demande de nous
rencontrer et sans cynisme de ma part je
m'interroge à ce moment-là je me dis
mais est ce qu on dit merci à des gens
qui vous ont ramené à mort quand je
présente au projet quand je présente
pardon aux équipes le projet la demande
en fait elle me reprenne de volée elle
me dit mais c'est nous qui demandons à
voir la famille c'est nous qui voulons
aller à la rencontre de ce qu'était
adrien c'est pas un processus classique
en fait dans notre activité
finalement on fait les secours parfois
ça se passe bien
jamet responsable en fait des accidents
dans notre métier on n'est pas des
sauveteurs on est des secouristes on
essaye d'apporter une réponse on change
pas une équation la vie la mort pourtant
en fait avec cette demande et cette
acceptation de cette rencontre de ce
temps de partage
c'est allé plus loin de tout ça c'est
finalement trouvé un sens un peu plus
profonds aux activités qu'on peut faire
au quotidien et donner du temps à
l'autre accepter partager une émotion
pour dire votre peine
c'est un peu la mienne parce que
finalement adrien on le connaissait et
c'est important qu'on partage qui il
était pour mieux comprendre et peut-être
n'ont pas mieux le servir mais à voir
comme il forme de buzz boom qu'on est
capable de se passer les uns sur les
autres sur nos blessures ça ça donne du
sens en tout cas je le crois je les ai
vus à travers le regard de des personnes
qui ont oeuvré pour tenter de sauver est
dans la logique dans la continuité de ce
moment savoir donner savoir regarder
l'autre savoir donner du temps à ce
dernier
j'apporte un corollaire
c'est finalement essayé de se faire
passer en seconde pas essayé en fait se
faire passer en seconde c'est l'histoire
de d'antoine qu'1 d un des gendarmes
secouristes qui sert au sein de l'unité
antoine il a eu un accident grave
en fait il vient de voir préalablement
il me dit il faut que j'aie le projetj
je vais partir faire cette course parce
qu'il faut que je
il faut que je prépare le diplôme de la
guide de haute montagne diplôme
exigeants et ils avaient déjà une grande
compétence professionnelle il voulait
encore plus d'oeuvrer à rendre cette
expertise palpable au quotidien et qui
puisse servir l'unité
le collectif donc il s'engage dans cette
voie et il nous est il part en
entraînement que je valide une voie
engagée dans le massif du mont blanc
entre ceux qui connaissent c'est le
super couloir en fait c'est pour ceux
qui ne sont pas prêts c'est l'enfer lui
il ya un peu avec l'élégance de
l'excellence c'est un c'est un vrai beau
grimpeur
malheureusement ça se passe pas comme on
l'aurait voulu et y'a une chute 30 m
terrible en fait le lendemain le jour
même par dont on est au bureau
rassembler et on prend cet appel du pghm
de chamonix unités voisines qui nous dit
on à récupérer antoine
il est à l'hôpital c'est grave c'est les
seuls éléments qu'on aime c'est la
sidération
c'est une équipe qu'il faut ressouder et
surtout par dessus tout c'est une
famille parce que antoine il a une jeune
épouse il a
john en forme il faut leur dire et ça
c'est ma responsabilité papa il rentrera
pas ce soir vous avez une nuit qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'angoise peu importe
là encore le prix à payer c'est pas
grave c'est pas moi qui suis important
c'est elle qui qui est dans la tente qui
n'a que des incertitudes et c'est
antoine et au petit matin il ya sans
doute ce que je qualifierais d'un
miracle une équipe médicale un médecin
qui nous disent voilà antoine va vivre
il va continuer à vivre et il pourra
réécrire et la page
super mais non pas super parce qu'en
fait des régents dans mon institution
qui sont peut-être pas les plus
intéressants qui sont peut-être pas les
plus nombreux mais qui n'ont pas tout à
fait penser comme moi et qui lui ont dit
le surlendemain de son opération
antoine
sinon si moi t'es pas prêt le secours en
montagne c'est terminé
c'était sa vie en toile alors vous avez
quelqu'un qui revient plus ou moins de
la mort et à qui vous dit ça vous êtes
sûr que vous avez adopté la meilleure
démarche pour le détruire intérieurement
et on a pris ça en compte avec antoine
il voulait revenir il est revenu et moi
je lui ai dit toi tu t'occupes de toi tu
fais ce que tu as à faire tu te
réveilles tu reviens que recouvre t
capacité pleine capacité
et moi je m'occupe des des nuisibles
parce que je n'ai pas d'autres pertes
herman j'ai pas lu ma carrière je vais
pas lui on a toujours deux choix dans
ses positions
soit je fais comme tout le monde et puis
je laisse la tête
soit je me révèle et je dis ça parce que
ça et c'est pas passé c'est pas moi
qu'il s'agit de regarder et aujourd'hui
antoine qui à nouveau dans une unité
spécialisée qui à nouveau fait son
métier
le fait encore de la plus belle des
manières
et rayonne dans son excellence
réellement c'est le vrai témoignage
qu'il faut entendre et peut-être en
filigrane voir qu'à un moment un chef
c'est là pour servir et moi on me
concernant j'avais fait ce choix là de
dire finalement antoine tu as plus de
valeur que moi étaient plus importants
que moi et je le pense encore
sincèrement oui je passerai en second
plan
oui c'est pas grave c'est le prix à
payer c'est ma carrière tant mieux tant
mieux ou tant pis c'est selon mais en
attendant toi parce que tu le veux on va
tout donner pour tu puisses passé il
revenir et se partage à travers ces deux
anecdotes c'est regarder l'autre c'est
une chose savoir s'oublier et peut-être
d'aller plus loin
consiste à aller plus loin et c'est ça à
mon sens qui fait qui fait sens à une
heure où on se pose beaucoup de
questions sur l'engagement de ses
collaborateurs
c'est partout pareil qu'est ce que je
fais comment je le fais pourquoi je le
fais moi quand celle qui m'a accompagné
durant ces 15 dernières années et que
j'ai rencontrés alors on a dit à qui
j'ai dit écoute moi mon rêve c'est
d'aller en pghm commandé 1 p g cham les
15 premières secondes
marie volet gentiment au nez parce qu'un
peu ghm qu'est ce que c'est dans le fond
c'est pas trop les quinze suivante
en fait elle m'a dit
tu es sans doute un peu fou je te crois
et je suive les 15 années suivantes elle
c'est oublier pas complètement parce que
elle a vécu mais elle m'a donné les
moyens de rendre ce rêve réalisable
cette attention à l'autre ce désintérêt
comporta soit je sais pas si c'est la
réponse à tous les problèmes managériaux
qu'on rencontre dans les entreprises je
dis que c'est un pas vers l'humanité
vers ce qu'on a plus précieux en chacun
de nous on pourrait le dire ainsi
cette vertu de la gentillesse c'est pas
une faiblesse c'est au contraire une
force de caractère une force d'âme qui
vous permet de regarder l'autre non pas
à travers ce qu'il est à travers ce que
vous êtes mais à travers ce qu'il est
lui pour non pas s'élever soi mais c'est
les levés lui ont parlé tout à l'heure
de augmenté l'autre c'est de ça dont il
s'agit c'est en chacun de nous c'est un
choix qu'on fait je vous invite à le
partager et et à vivre cette gentillesse
pour ce qu'elle est vous serez libre
vous vivrez loin et vous verrez vrai
pour l'autre qui vous donnerait toutes
les chances merci
[Musique]